então eu queria falar um pouco pra vocês
de coragem e de prática de colocar em
ação aquilo que nós é realmente
[Música]
aprendamos com a coragem ou aquilo que é
a coragem pé de nós é eu sou nilza eu
gostaria de informar que a minha força
formação não é formal mas eu sou
bacharel em ser metida o que significa
que em cada projeto voluntário ou não
foram todos voluntários até aqui que eu
me dedico eu sou autodidata e é de bico
estudo muito pra que o projeto seja
realizado do melhor modo possível também
sou agricultura orgânica no sítio do rio
do braço e o sítio tem este nome em
homenagem ao rio que ali passa e para
caracterizar que extinguiu ali se chama
rio do braço
então eu não vou entrar nos seus
detalhes que o rio já tinha saído do
mapa e certo exceto ela foi recolocado e
tal e isso já faz parte de todo o
propósito que nós vamos ver adiante a
questão da água me chamou muita atenção
e eu acho que já quando criança também
me preocupou porque é como a roberta
falou eu tive uma vida muito feliz
é como os meus três irmãos meus pais
minha família à vida que a gente tinha
também
só porque um rio estava presente à lei
eu queria chamar a atenção de vocês para
o vinculou do uso da água entre
agricultura e produção de alimentos
então se nós teremos escassez de água
nós teremos uma redução muito maior de
produção de alimentos e temos que
considerar também que dos 22 por cento
para consumo industrial e 8% do consumo
doméstico muito desta água vai também
para a produção de alimentos de forma
direta ou indireta é não idade rural que
eu nasci eu conheci um rio com essas
caraterísticas essa é a família vizinha
e era um rio que na da agentina dava
tomava banho fazia corrida de quem nada
dava mais que eu mergulhava melhor
pescava lavava roupa com a minha mãe a
minha avó e todos usavam o rio para esta
finalidade e algumas pessoas para
consumo ou menos muito menos de 50 anos
o rio ficou deste modo é o mesmo cenário
é o mesmo lugar fotografado os news eles
não desaparecem por si só por algum
fenômeno climático pode até ser um
fenômeno extremo que contribua
mas os rios a água ela tem desaparecido
no planeta por interferência na oferta
dos seres humanos
esse caminho de moça que parece um
caminho da roça que vocês estão vendo
aqui no meio é o leito do rio do braço
próximo à estrada da ilha à direita são
lagos de mineração à esquerda no
loteamento e lá atrás
a serra do mar podem também observar que
cena bonita né
e quando nós vimos então a
principalmente eu vi essas imagens de
tudo morto e nem gerou muita preocupação
em que é a aflição e inquietação e l
eu comecei a me preparar pra porque já
tinha entendido mais ou menos o que
aconteceu mas de uma forma bem lycra né
é o que aconteceu com o rio e essa
vontade de revitalizar o rio colocando
água de volta no rio foi se aguçando
estas duas imagens são do mesmo local
que eu mostrei a pouco é quando nós já
começamos a pensar num projeto de fato e
aqui a direita é um desenho feito no
computador é por um amigo de uma ong que
é pra gente poder mostrar para as
pessoas como que as pessoas que
trabalhariam no projeto de revitalização
gostariam que o rio fu é ficasse e foi
com esta figura que muitas pessoas
compreenderam e abriram é e então na
questão da coragem é exigiu determinação
e amor porque a gente não faz
é o não sensibiliza para um trabalho
maior se a gente não ama lá no fundo
não estou dizendo de amar
fisiologicamente um dinho o
fisiologicamente um pedaço de terra ou
uma propriedade mas o que isso
representa como meio ambiente como a
natureza e para a humanidade
então é o por exemplo as funções do rio
né
é porque precisamos tanto deles pra que
que a água serve
vocês viram ali né então não que ele
houvesse necessidade para a agricultura
mas e os ecossistemas e o processo
industrial e os empregos e tetra e
comecei a me perguntar muito o que é
hesitou se é uma realização financeira
de comprar bens ou se é a realização de
um sonho
através de algum projeto que o dinheiro
não compra nem paga ou ambos
e isso exige uma decisão porque nem
sempre dá pra ter os dois como eu tinha
me proposto a trabalhar de cor
coordenadora do projeto de revitalização
isso também exigiria atitudes da mudança
em mim mesma em outras pessoas
e quando a gente precisa provocar
mudanças em algum lugar e talvez algumas
atividades ali existentes não sejam mais
possíveis
isso não significa uma afronta contra
alguém então a abordagem sempre foi
feita de modo até carinhoso conversável
explicados nem todos entendem
gil nem todos aceitavam é mais como um
caminho vamos encontrar um novo caminho
é de uma outra forma para que fosse
possível continuar é alguma então é por
exemplo estou falando de alguma
atividade de intervenção tanto no rio ou
no entorno né então não bater de frente
de conversar de abordagem como se faz
com a verdade é esse o slide ele está um
pouco escuro e mas quando essa
fotografia foi feita nós já estávamos
num processo onde tinha uma equipe
multidisciplinar e é o formada que
escrevi estava escrevendo o projeto
formalmente pra encaminhar para os
órgãos ambientais para licenciamento já
tinha as parcerias feitas com
universidades aqui locais já tínhamos
orientações de outras universidades de
pessoas especializadas
é a gente já tinha toda uma
fundamentação para dar esse
encaminhamento e o item coragem ele
aparece seqüencialmente e nem
interruptamente que é de ter a coragem
de conversar com a comunidade porque
veja não é uma campanha política é é um
objetivo muito diferente de incentivar
pessoas a irem conosco a aceitarem a
engajar e também chegou num ponto onde
dentro da minha família eu tive que
então conversar com meu esposo ea gente
tinha três filhos
como seria essa distribuição de tempo
dos projetos do dinheiro e de vida então
é meu esposo ele foi um grande
incentivador ele tinha uma macrovisão
muito boa de toda a bacia e do
hidrográfica e de como fazer esse
processo e quanto dinheiro nós decidimos
que a gente não precisava literalmente
de uma casa na praia uma casa no campo
o fazer tantas viagens mas também não
precisava deixar de ir e achamos o meter
é essa imagem da canoa
eu trouxe pra mostrar que é falar sobre
segurança sobre confiança quando basf é
queremos desenvolver alguma algum
trabalho ou vender algum produto se nós
apresentamos de verdade como de fato é
falar a verdade sempre cabem mais
pessoas na canoa porque ela não é uma
canoa furada ela é de bem coletivo e
assim o quebra-cabeças foice se juntando
a nós fizemos vários desfiles colocamos
outdoor diz nunca como protesto mas com
alegria pra mostrar para as pessoas no
slogan venho até nós nos ajudem façam
parte desse time
para a nossa surpresa rapidamente foram
chegando pessoas pessoas muito
qualificadas e que de algum modo queriam
participar é também tivemos que
reconhecer a nossa humildade de que a
gente sabia muito pouco e sempre fomos
atrás de pessoas especializadas
aqui é uma reunião na universidade nós
que demos outras reuniões em outras
universidades onde o professor disse o
seguinte olha é nilza eu só tenho uma
hora de intervalo de almoço quando o que
eu posso falar com vocês mas eu também
precisa almoçar a então tá bom
professora se for possível a gente vai
em algum lugar enquanto mostra conversa
e tal e aí foi uma cena e linda porque
ele tinha comprado um lanchinho para
cada um uma garrafa de água colocado no
chão os livros todos mais ou menos
conforme o que a gente conversou ele
disse o seguinte esse material aqui é
meu
vocês me digam o que vocês precisam e eu
empresto e vocês vão pra casa e num
outro momento vocês me chamo né
então a gente saía de lá se né quanto
humildade quanto aprendizado foi lindo é
estudos constantes
é o projeto do rio do braço ainda está
longe de ser concluído porque acabou
ficando no sítio uma é o sítio do rio do
braço como unidade didática do projeto
de revitalização e não é que a gente
planta uma árvore neste ano daqui a dois
anos tem uma floresta leva sete anos que
a floresta primária
depois de sete anos ela começa a morrer
aparece a floresta secundária têm que
introduzir alguma coisa vem
aleatoriamente pela própria natureza ou
não até chegar nas climáticas
aqui nós vamos ver algumas imagens de
limpeza do rio para restabelecimento do
leito que não podia alargar retificar
nem aprofundar porque a vida do rio
depende também dessa irregularidade a
gente não vai falar sobre isso
a plantação de mata ciliar também com
seria de idosos crianças alunos é pra e
um outro aprendizado muito importante
que a gente teve com o tempo das coisas
né
o tempo da natureza aquilo que acabei de
falar de falar que a floresta tem seu
tempo
a natureza tem seu tempo e nós temos que
nos dar o direito do tempo da espera e
se caga do lado de lá é só para ilustrar
né então anda no meu passo que eu te
acompanho se você correr
vamos nos separar é isso aqui são os
cenários do rio seco é as imagens falam
por si do rio assoreado a avifauna
voltando é ninguém vai introduzir
animais ou árvores
os três vaz trazem naturalmente de volta
alimento água e abrigo e no plantio da
mata ciliar foram plantadas muitas
árvores frutíferas e muitas delas é de
alimento de frutas hoje o rio está sim e
aí nasceu um novo projeto que levou a
ser agricultura orgânica né e era o meu
sonho de vida e faz parte desse projeto
de pureza do rio em cancún o tempo é de
pureza do rio de não levar agrotóxicos e
venenos para essa água porque alguém vai
se envenenar com ela então durmo
tranqüilo feliz
e é isso